la dalle enfants à parler de régression
et de classification linéaire pour
résoudre le problème de l'apprentissage
superviser en gros l'idée c'est que l'on
à un nuage de pointe dans un espace de
phil jones et chaque point est associé
un live ball par exemple like dislike
elles ont cherché à décrire ce nuage au
point à l'aide d'une description simple
fait de droite ou si l'on est en
dimensions supérieures à l'aide d'hyper
plan est la raison pour laquelle on
adore ses approche linéaire c'est parce
qu'ils ont de supers propriété en
particulier elles peuvent être calculés
efficacement par des algorithmes comme
la méthode des moindres carrés la
régression logistique
svm ou encore le percepteur y compris
quand l'espace des phisheurs et de
grandes dimensions
oui j'ai pas parlé du percepteur la
dernière fois mon gros ça fait la même
chose que la régression logistique ou
svr mais il ya un mais le problème du
machine learning linéaire c'est qu'ils
ne marche que si les données ont une
structure linéaire c'est à dire c'est le
coefficient de régression air carré
épreuve terrain dans le cas de la
régression linéaire ou si les level sont
séparables par un hyper plan dans le cas
de la classification linéaire or ça en
général assez pas le cas voici par
exemple les nombres d'abonnés de 115
chaînes youtube scientifiques les
données datent d'août 2010 est donc
elles sont pas tout à fait à jour mais
la lueur d'un combat sans doute pas trop
changé depuis
vous voulez que cette courbe n'a
vraiment pas une structure linéaire
en fait comme on aurait pu s'y attendre
elle suit à peu près la loi de ce type
c'est à dire que c'est x et le
classement de la chaîne alors son nombre
d'abonnés va être y à peu près égale à
1,5 millions / x et le problème c'est
que pour trouver une relation comme y
était bien là c / x bats avec une
régression linéaire c'est mort tout ça
parce que cette relation n'est pas une
relation linéaire entre eux y est x oui
je rappelle qu'une relation linéaire
c'est y est égal à ax puce b mais du
coup y'a t'il quand même en moyens
d'utiliser la puissance de la régression
linéaire pour déterminer une relation
entre x et y
la réponse est oui mais pour y arriver
va falloir un peu faire une bidouille de
physiciens justement notre physicien
préféré de youtube david de la chaîne
sur ses taux nantes a justement
bidouiller les données pour faire
ressortir la loi de ziff en tant que
relation linéaire
l'astuce c'est de bidouiller y en a un
autre les bols qu'on va appeler grant y
ait de bidouiller x en un autre fischer
disons grand x et en trouvant la bonne
bidouille qui dans son carré la fonction
logarithme on se rend compte que la loi
de ziff y est égale ac /
serait écrit comme étant quand y est
égal à constante - 30x magie magie
en effet lorsque l'on trace loeb y en
fonction de l'oc ii x vous n'obtient
quelque chose qui ressemble à une droite
bon c'est pas tip top on va dire que ça
marche alors la bidouille il matheux
puristes ils vont pas aimer ça et pareil
si vous sacraliser les sciences et la
méthode scientifique pas désolé du
spoiler mais les sciences c'est avant
tout un énorme tas de bidules c'est
grâce à de telles vidéos et que les
physiciens ont déterminé l'équation de
goldbrook white que les biologistes ont
déterminé la lois de kepler que les
économistes ont déterminé l'équation de
coop douglas et que l'om sera choisi
d'utiliser lé indice de masse corporelle
on trouve ça partout en finance et dans
le milieu on appelle ça la méthode du
gué steam est et si vous êtes en mode
grove nerfs parce que c'est pas logique
je vous renvoie vers l'épisode 6
la science et la quête de théories
émergents pas de théorie véritablement
vrai fondée sur des mathématiques
élégante et pour faire ça la bidouille
c'est pas beau mais ça marche en
particulier ça permet d'exploiter les
algorithmes efficace de la régression
linéaire et de la classification
linéaire centre de travail et les
applications sont stupéfiantes par
exemple
considérant le caducc sort que j'ai
mentionné la semaine dernière louxor
n'est pas linéairement séparables
autrement dit n'existe pas de droite qui
séparent bien les like des dislike
comment peut-on utiliser la puissance de
la classification linéaire pour
néanmoins bien apprendre louxor alors
avant de traiter ce cas sophistiqués je
vous propose une version plus simple de
ce problème en dimensions 1
imaginons coordination un et qu'on a des
dislike juste quand hicks et entre -1 et
1 comment séparer linéairement des like
des dislike et bien l'astuce c'est
l'habitude on va poser grand x est égal
à x carré et on va faire la séparation
linéaire pour grant x plairait c'est
tout bête la séparation linéaire est
tout simplement le point de rupture 30 x
est égal à un cantique c'est inférieur à
1 n'a dé dislike et quantix est
supérieur à 1
on a des laïcs alors il une façon plus
élégante une façon géométrique de mieux
visualiser la chose
pour ce faire on reprend notre dimension
du petit x initial est ce qu'on va faire
ce qu on va rajouter une dimension qui
va être égal à x car et l'espace des
feature est alors de dimension 2 sauf
que cette fois on peut facilement
séparer les laïcs étaient dislike à
l'est
une droite joli nom de la même façon
pour séparer les likes des dislike et
dans le corps ce qu'on veut faire c'est
rajouter une dimension supplémentaire
avec des transformations non linéaire
défi tu as initiaux typiquement il peut
rajouter une dimension linéaire pour
obtenir un espace de dimension 3 de
sorte que les données se trouve
maintenant sur une espèce de selle de
cheval
auquel cas on pourra séparer les like
des dislike à l'aide d'un hyper plan
horizontal
cette astuce documentation de l'espace
des futures à l'aide de bidules non
linéaire et super utile en pratique si
votre régression ou classification
linéaire ne marche pas et bien rajouter
tout bêtement d'autres fishers rajoutant
des termes comme x car et xo cub depuis
106 x ou encore locke de x et tenter à
nouveau votre régression ou votre
classification nyha c'est une façon très
facile de mieux expliquer les données en
fait on peut même aller plus loin et
rajouter un nombre infini de dimension
oui vous avez bien entendu un nombre
infini de dimension alors pour que ça
marche bien il faut techniquement que
cet espace infini soit un espace de
gilberte c'est à dire en particulier qui
dispose d'un produit scalaires dit comme
ça c'est pas super rassurant puisque une
fine et on veut que les calculs puisse
être fait par un ordinateur et les
ordinateurs et l'infini en général ça
fait pas bon ménage
forte heureusement on peut démontrer que
la séparation optimale sera orthogonale
à l'espace engendrés par les données ce
qui signifie qu'elle sera identifié par
un nombre fini de nombre en fait autant
de nombreux qu'il ya de tonner nous
encore le calcul de cette séparation
optimale pourra se faire en un temps
polynomiale ans le nombre de données et
tout ce dont on aura besoin c'est de la
fonction qui étant donné de feature x et
exprime calcule le produit scalaires
entre les bidules non linéaire 2x et
exprime dans l'espace de gilberte cette
astuce remarquable et ce que l'on
appelle le coeur numérique
elle est très utilisée en pratique bon
je sens que j'en ai perdu plus d'un dans
cette explication si j'ai pas tout suivi
ses parts à tout ce que je voulais avoir
dit c'est que c'est utile en pratique de
faire beaucoup de bidouille dans des
espaces de gilberte de dimension infinie
surtout si c'est pour trouver une
classification linéaire et je vous
renvoie vers les vidéos de wanted a à ce
sujet pour plus de détails techniques à
ces sujets alors tout ce que je raconte
la peut sembler être une tentative
désespérée
quoique pas si moche de sauver les
algorithmes de classification ligne
mais si c'était juste ça je vous en aura
pas parler en fait cette bidouille non
linéaire c'est aussi et surtout ce que
font les meilleurs algorithmes de
machine learning d'aujourd'hui oui je
parle notamment des algues au rythme du
diplôme ning
en gros le diplôme ning s'est enchaîné
plein de classification linéaire pour
bidouiller l'espace des features de
manière non linéaire
oui parce que souvenez vous conteront
fait de la classification linéaire on a
une étape de couture à la fin aussi
appelé fonction d'activation qui est une
opération de non linéaire le diplôme
ning bidouille donc les features de
manière non linéaire pour keane fine et
les features bidouiller deviennent
linéaments séparables par la dernière
couche du diplo ning autrement dit le
diplôme hing c'est automatiser la
bidouille non linéaire encore une fois
si ça vous dépasse ne vous inquiétez pas
reparlera de tout ça plus longuement
un autre truc assez cool pour visualiser
ce qui se passe c'est de prendre la
séparation linéaire des features
bidouiller et de projeter cette
séparation dans l'espace des phisheurs
initiaux on obtient alors une séparation
non linéaire de l'espace qui par exemple
dans le cas du luxe hors correspond à un
découpage de l'espace en plusieurs
morceaux en fait de façon générale si on
s'autorise toutes les bidules nominé à
imaginables notamment en passant par des
espaces de gilberte de dimension infinie
on finira toujours par réussir à séparer
les like des dislike et ça c'est cool
c'est aussi embêtant
après tout si j'ai une erreur de mesure
et en science empirique il ya toujours
énormément d'erreurs de mesures je suis
certain que quelque part dans ce
processus je vais mal conclure à cause
de cette erreur de mesure
pareil si les figures sont théoriquement
insuffisant pour des prédictions
déterministe et les bosses ce qui en
fait est toujours le cas vu qu'on
cherche uniquement des théories
émergentes
bref il semble en fait plus pertinent de
s'accorder le droit de ne pas
parfaitement séparer les like des dix
fake
en considérant que c'est normal que
notre modèle très incomplet soit
justement incomplet et en effet vouloir
à tout prix séparer les laïcs et des
dislike c'est une erreur de base d'une
machine learning to come de
l'apprentissage en général que l'on
appelle la surinterprétation ou lover
fitting mais ça on en reparle la semaine
prochaine un harfang n'a parlé de
récréation et de classification linéaire
il vous avez posé le problème du rrq
sort gabriel frais et benoît avril avait
proposé d'utiliser de droite de
célébration plutôt qu'une
le problème c'est les questions cherche
à faire ça tel quel
on n'a pas gagné au rythme simple de
calcul de ces deux droites de séparation
est en fait de façon générale cherché à
trouver ces deux droites correspond à
résoudre un problème d'optimisation on
appelle non convexe bref tout ça pour
dire que c'est un problème qui a de
bonnes chances de ne pas être résolus de
façon très générale par des séries qu'au
rythme api un autre problème avec
utilisation de deux droites plutôt
qu'une
c'est que bon ben ok pour le coeur en
effet de droite c'était une bonne idée
mais si on prend d'autres structures
d'autres aux répartitions
comment est ce qu'on fait pour choisir
un nombre de droits de séparation
comment est ce qu'on les place
bref en fait on s'attarde or sur le
point tu duc sort uniquement fait
justement parce qu'on appelle de lover
fitting surinterprétation c'est à dire
qu'on cherche pas uniquement ajoutons ce
problème alors que le problème du
machine tournait bien plus générale est
qu'il faut être capable d'adresser
toutes sortes de données vous avez aussi
demandé de réfléchir à la question à ce
qu'il valait mieux la méthode des
moindres des nations de la place et de
le post kobe tu vois ce qu'il valait
mieux à la méthode des moindres carrés
de gosse et legendre et luc morin alors
y fait remarquer que la méthode des
moindres carrés à la volt ou bien se
prêter au calcul est en effet les
calculs notamment en dimensions un an
dimension 2 de la méthode des moindres
car elles sont beaucoup plus facile que
la méthode des moindres déviation de la
place et moscovitch ceci dit ce n'est
plus vraiment voit déjà en dimensions
supérieures notamment la méthode des
moindres qui a ré demande à inverser une
matrice est un calcul inverse d'une
matrice en ce moment des grandes matrice
à la main c'est quand même pas facile
pour pouvoir sur avec des ordinateurs ça
se fait très très très bien en fait les
deux approches même toit des moindres
carrés et la méthode de boscovich et la
place des moindre déviation sont toutes
les deux des approches qui sont en fait
quelques aveux très rapidement par des
ordinateurs vous dis que ce sont les
algorithmes qui ont du temps de calcul
paulino bio en la dimension de l'espace
--en le nombre de données donc en effet
avant l'avènement des ordinateurs et
méthode des moindres des carrés et est
beaucoup plus pratique et ça explique en
grande partie pourquoi elle était
utilisée plutôt que la méthode du
moindre déviation ensuite luc morin
allait faire marrer cas beaucoup de
faiblesses en justifications théoriques
et de la méthode des moindres carrés
avant de vous en parler il faut que je
vous parle du théorème centrale limite
de la place
en gros ce que ses théorèmes 10 et que
d'une certaine manière si une erreur est
une somme d'un nombre infini de petites
perturbations aléatoire et indépendante
publiquement si vous faites une mesure
maya plein de petites erreurs dans la
mesure
différentes étapes de la mesure qui
s'ajoute qu'ils font une erreur global
le théorème centre halimi s'est dit que
quand il ya plein de telles petites
perturbations infinitésimale et
indépendante
alors les erreurs seront distribués
selon une loi normale
on peut aussi la loi haïtienne j'ai pas
pourquoi on l'appelle côté nord la place
avait tout inventé
excusez mon organisme la place tien est
ce qu'il y avait que cette distribution
gaussienne sait que sa fonction de
densité s'écrit bla bla bla
exponentielle - bla bla bla erreur ou
carré
on suppose maintenant que les élans sont
indépendantes est identiquement
distribués alors la probabilité d'avoir
toutes les erreurs qu'on a eus va être
égal au produit des probabilités
d'erreur c'est à dire en produit des bla
bla bla exponentielle - bla bla bla
erreur au carré et sachant que le
produit d'expérience y est l'été galal
exponentielle de la somme ça ça nous
fait blablabla fois exponentielle de
moins bla bla bla fois la somme des
carrés des erreurs ensuite ce que
propose de faire une place c'est de
choisir les paramètres de la régression
linéaire qui rendent les erreurs les
plus crédible possible est plus probable
qu'ils soient
c'est ce qu'on appelle la méthode de la
vraisemblance on va maximiser la
vraisemblance des données sachant les
paramètres en fait maximiser cette
expression ça revient à minimiser la
somme des cas et comme il ya beaucoup
d'erreurs qui sont en fait une
simulation de petites erreurs qui
suivent du coup l'album gaussienne on en
déduit que la méthode des moindres
carrés est compatible avec l'hypothèse
du cac sur laquelle les erreurs sont
distribués chaunois dossier voilà comme
l'expliquent paradoxe la justification
de la place de la méthode des moindres
carrés et via la distribution gaussienne
des erreurs mais tout ça suppose bien
sûr que les erreurs sont distribués
selon une caution bon faut aussi
admettre qu'il faut utiliser le maximum
de bresson d'anciens hésite - payet
c'est là que moi mais qui reviendra une
autre fois en particulier en pratique
les erreurs ne suivent pas
nécessairement une loi gaussienne en
particulier un truc qui peut arriver
assez souvent c'est que justin est rare
qui a été complètement mal fait
voilà peut-être que l'expérience qu'il
fallait faire ces tests et c'est pas un
truc sur l'acide sulfurique et peut-être
qu'à une expérience ou n'a oublié de
mettre l'acide sulfurique et du cou et
des résultats complètement aberrant à ce
moment là la distribution des erreurs
avaient pas une gaussienne mais c'est
peut-être en général une gaussienne
bêtes et on n'entend on pas voir des
trucs complètement absurde si à ce
moment là les erreurs ne suivent pas
cette loi sociale
alors la méthode des moindres car il
peut donner des trucs complètement
aberrant et ça en pratique imaginer
qu'aujourd'hui on automatise énormément
les procédures d analyse de données
ça alors le truc ça arrive tout le temps
on parle typiquement de donner aux
flyers l'intérieur c'est une donnée qui
vont vers elle et la n va pas forcément
envie de l'expliquer et comme le fait
remarquer plus tôt au rwanda chaillet le
problème de la méthode des moindres
carrés c'est qu'elle va donner beaucoup
plus d'importance
les points qui sont très très éloigné
des autres points elle va donner
énormément d'importance ou servent
d'ailleurs
et ça en pratique c'est un énorme défaut
de la méthode des moindres car il est du
coup là on peut lui préférer la méthode
de posco beach la place parce que celle
ci sera beaucoup plus robuste elle ne
donnera pas plus d'importance est un
point très éloignées qui est un point
qui a un peu éloigné à avoir avec le
fait que la dérive et d'un car et c'est
proportionnel au nombre lui-même alors
que la dérivée d'une valeur absolue
toujours un vecteur unitaire qui dépend
pas du coup de la distance à laquelle se
trouve la donne est pour ça que je parle
de tout ça bien plus longuement pour
expliquer cette journée on dit que la
méthode de boscovich la place et robuste
aux erreurs ou encore qu'est l'art
brighton de 0,5 zeller que typiquement
c'est quelqu'un de malveillant peut
modifier quelques unes de vos données
il peut ainsi essayer de [ __ ] le
bordel dans votre analyse de données non
si vous utilisez la méthode des moindres
car ils vous serez très vulnérables à ce
genre d'attaqués mais si vous utilisez
la méthode de boscovich en place et à
des moindre déviation
alors vous serez robuste à ce genre
d'attaqués en effet la pouvoir modifier
un petit peu votre analyse hédonique
mais votre analyse de données ne sera
pas énormément perturbé elle sera encore
assez représentative des données non
modifiés tout ça est en fait extrêmement
similaire à la différence contre la
moyenne et la médiane la moyenne en fait
c'est la méthode des moindres carrés
quand il ya aucun fishers qu'on cherche
à expliquer à donner sans aucun fil d'or
je cherche un résumé avec 1 seconde la
moyenne c'est ce qui va mobiliser la
somme des carrés des erreurs en disant
que la moyenne représente a donné par
que le média et ceux qui minimisent la
somme des déviations et la médiane est
beaucoup plus robuste
c'est à dire que si on a une
distribution et comprend un point qui
est déjà au dessus de la médiane et que
l'on envoie jusqu'à l'infini
on exagère on fait n'importe quoi avec
alors les médias ne va pas du tout bougé
bref tout ça pour dire que la méthode de
post coït sa place en fait en pratique
c'est pas mal mais ce n'est pas
suffisant notamment pour le baliser un
que je suis comme luc morin alors if le
fait remarquer peut-être que plus x est
grand plus les variations de y sont
grandes et à ce moment là ce qu'on
aimerait c'est que la régression
linéaire prennent en compte ce fait et
on ne cherche pas forcément à coller aux
données avec des grandes valeurs de x
puisqu'on sait que ces grandes bird et
qui sont allés à des grandes
fluctuations du coup on peut pas faire
confiance à chacune des données
individuelles alors que peut-être que
les petites valeurs de xl pour mort sur
le coup plus fiables à ce moment là y'a
pleins d'astuces pour essayer de mieux
coller à cette structure des données
bref pouvait qu'en général le projet de
régression linéaire est en fait beaucoup
beaucoup plus compliquée que ce qui est
pas fonctionné à l'école et on pourrait
même considérer que c'est un problème
encore non résolues en tout cas donc il
n'ya pas de solution satisfaisant sauf
si on est bayésiens alors ne pas pouvoir
prendre le temps donc bien pu
s'expliquer ce que ça signifie de
vraiment être bayésiens mais un aspect
important du paysagisme c'est le fait
qu' on ne fait jamais confiance à un
seul modèle à la fois qui en fait utile
de faire confiance à plusieurs modèles
incompatible à la fois en particulier on
y gagne et souvent à faire de
prédictions qui est une combinaison de
plusieurs modèles à la fois et ça dès
lors on reviendra dessus dans cette
série en particulier pour un malaisien
de prédiction sera fiable que si c'est
la même prédiction qui est fait par tous
les modèles de régression linéaire dont
je vous ai parlé et ça c'est génial
parce que ça permet aussi aux plaisirs
de mesurer l'étendue de son ignorance
s'il différents modèles prédisent des
valeurs différentes
alors le parisien va pouvoir conclure
qu'il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes à avoir
quant à toute prédiction de l'evole mais
bon comme vous l'imaginez il y aurait
encore beaucoup plus à dire sur le bail
zenit aurait un perdriau et commentaires
signalent le fait qu'ils ont un petit
peu lâché dans la vidéo précédente
j'imagine aussi ça tu as dur aussi pour
cette vidéo si vous n'avez pas tout
compris c'est plus que normal notamment
ou simplement parce que j'ai donné
aucune définition rigoureuse et juste de
donner une idée
vidéos précédentes notamment de ce qui
était une corrélation de ce que pouvait
être des variations de giteau n'a aucune
définition au format note le conseil de
base que j'ai à vous donner c'est de
regarder les vidéos plusieurs fois ça
aide d'intérioriser au fur à mesure
toutes les étapes des raisonnements des
vidéos n'hésitez pas à mettre pause
notamment de prendre le temps de
réfléchir à donner mais enfin si vous
n'avez pas tout compris c'est pas grave
du tout les trucs importants vraiment
retenir en fait ces trucs très basique
très important à retenir c'est à quoi
ressemble le problème de l'apprentissage
supervisé qui elle est en gros la
philosophie de la régression linéaire au
tracé d'une droite effet réflexion avec
la droite ou de la classification ine a
tracé un hyper pente vers la traduction
de quel côté de l'hyper plan mené il
faut aussi retenir que les calculs sont
très rapides à faire par un ordinateur
mais que le problème c'est que parfois
cette régression linéaire cette case
fille solitaire ne marche pas ce qu'on a
vu aujourd'hui c'est une façon de faire
en sorte que ça marche tout le temps et
ce qui va être encore plus intéressant
dans les vidéos à venir c'est que ce
n'est pas forcément une bonne chose de
faire en sorte que cette séparation
linéaire typique où on va vraiment
marché qui en fait souhaitable de faire
des erreurs
du moins d'inclure le fait qu'il y à des
erreurs de données enfin didier muller
me fait remarquer que en fait la photo
de legendre que j'utilisais les nerfs
fois et pas une photo de rater les maris
le jean dans les cimes photo d'un
politicien français lui le gendre et le
problème c'est que quatrième mari le
genre bon connais pas de photo de lui à
part cette caricature que je trouve
assez horrible le mec il a quand même
inventé la méthode la plus utilisée
aujourd'hui en sciences il fonça
régression linéaire c'est peut-être pour
avoir le truc le plus utilisé dans
science était la plus value et le pauvre
legendre la seule image connais de lui
c'est une caricature absolument horrible
elle espère que vous avez aimé cet
épisode à partir de la prochaine vidéo
et pour plusieurs vidéos on va parler du
problème le plus fondamental en fait
d'une machine learning et de
l'apprentissage statistiques de façon
générale qui est le problème de leurs
critiques
la surinterprétation va voir que c'est
vraiment un problème extrêmement notre
idéal que beaucoup considèrent encore
non résolus aujourd'hui et on va voir
que ce problème de sur interprétations
de pervitine c'est un problème qui nous
concerne directement à lustin panne de
machine learning d'intelligence
artificielle
c'est un problème de vue harding
d'apprentissage est le problème
l'intelligence si vous avez aimez cette
vidéo pensez à la ligue et à la
commenter avait partagé pense à vous
abonner pour sur l'épisode merci aux
tireurs fous leurs dons et j'espère que
la prochaine fois
comment est-ce que tu le fais pour
calculer le taux d'intérêt que tu vas
demander on rigole ça fait paniquer rim
dit penser qu'une idée eh ben il existe
une formule presque magique qui permet
de calculer ce risque elle est très peu
connu du grand public mais elle est
applicable à n'importe quel
investissement
il s'agirait de la méthode du doigt
mouillé une feinte this is your ride
your bicycle machine onyango redemption
déjà on y parle depuis causé des fuites
de djeddah it can be gouraya tu crées
news show room une fugueuse lusine dans
l'ignorance formation in den plas y
ayant opté charles les machines
ordinaires gordon tu vises dame antonio
piccioni be careful d'aulnat tu as tout
mini new features d'une attitude over
feat et or training 7